hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about the oh seikomi
waza so this is a continuation of our
kumiuchi series so we're covering all
the pieces of kumiuchi remember kumiuchi
means struggle and aikido ideally
kumiuchi is something we would like to
never do so we would like to never have
to use any of these things if we had
really good eye key we wouldn't have to
do any of this stuff but this is stuff
we're doing when our ikea is starting to
fail so osekomiwaza is something that if
you've been following my approach to
aikido you might say why would you even
put ose komiwaza in your aikido because
it's just pinning techniques and pinning
techniques are domination techniques and
you christopher hines say that aikido is
not about dominating it's about making a
chords
that is true but there are times where
we have to struggle that's what the
whole kumiuchi is about right so if we
could always make perfect ikey then we
wouldn't have to have anything in the
kumiuchi and osekomiwaza is just an
extension of that i think the
osekomewaza is in aikido to teach you
some very important things it's one how
to deal with taking down an armed person
and two and controlling the armed person
also and two how to deal with pinning
someone and there being other people
around who could come and get you so if
other people could come to get you how
would we pin someone right so there
might be times where you have to pin you
can't make the accord you want and so
you have to hold someone down and
dominate them but in aikido we always
want to do it in a way with thought
towards being autonomous
so i'm going to cover that stuff today
i'm going to show you all the different
little ideas about pinning and all the
different parts that come into pinning
i'm going to call my over here we're
going to go to work maya
all right so let's talk about ose
komiwaza
to me the osekome waza fits really
naturally in i think a lot of people
might say that that doesn't seem to fit
my approach and as i said in the in the
teaser in the beginning it's because
kumiuchi overall doesn't fit with the
ideal aikido situation
but like all good systems it's built to
deal with situations as they get worse
and worse and worse so meaning a bad
system can only deal with when things go
right right if they go wrong then a bad
system can't deal with that a good
system can deal with it going wrong and
wrong again and wrong again and wrong
again and wrong again that's what a
system does is it builds in redundancies
that help you get back to where you want
to be the difference in my approach to
aikido and maybe how it's commonly seen
is the goal in my idea of aikido the
goal is to make a chord right is to
peacefully resolve the situation now
there might have to be punching and
kicking and holding all kinds of stuff
to resolve the situation but the idea is
to get a
situation that's good for both of us as
good as it can possibly be
i believe other systems like you know
the ideas is a really simple idea which
is to dominate the other person and
that's kind of a caveman way of looking
at things in my opinion which is like if
i crush the other person i'll have to do
what i say and that's that now the
unrealistic way of looking at the world
in my opinion is that everything's
butterflies and rainbows and that
everyone's gonna do want to get along
and everything's great
now that i've give you a philosophical
breakdown
let's talk about st comey was and that's
relevant because jose kamawaza is
dominating someone it's holding someone
down
i think one important thing to
understand with all the aikido take down
things and this is one of the big things
as i've begun to release this material
people have argued with me about and
said like oh the takedowns in aikido are
dumb so why would you even need those
pins because the takedowns are so bad
they're never going to work now i do
agree that the takedowns in aikido are
not the best takedowns you could use
ever period meaning if i just want to
take maya down shooting to her legs or
getting her body tied up and throwing
her over or tripping her are the best
ways to get her to go down to the ground
those are the best ways to get down go
down to the ground the problem is in
aikido one we have to
deal with our historical context and
it's also our modern context which is if
she had a knife in her hand
and i shoot any kind of double leg she's
going to be cutting and stabbing at me
right so that's not going to work and
most of the time that i'm working to get
into my good clinch position right so
bit by bit as i'm trying to get into a
good clinch position she's cutting and
stabbing me the whole time while i'm
trying to get into these throw positions
that i'm getting into right so that's
bad and then two with multiple attackers
most of the high success take down so
even if i manage to get her hand so she
can't stab anymore this kind of throw
takes a long time to set up and all that
time that i'm working from this position
one of her friends is coming to get me
so with multiple attackers those kinds
of takedowns won't work either so what
aikido is teaching us to do is to deal
with situations and the takedowns that
we could possibly use for multiple
attackers and for armed people right so
meaning aikido i'm going to work of
course off the idea of her coming in to
attack me and that's what's going to set
up my takedown positions right is her
attacking me and trying to cover that
distance not me cutting the distance to
her but her trying to cover the distance
to me and all of those are done in a way
that i could abate those so if i if i
use that rokyo takedown that we just saw
right now so she comes in and i step
with the rope now rokio take down now
the second her friend comes i can bail
out of that rokio takedown and i'm in
good position right so that also it
deals with multiple attackers so all of
the aikido takedowns are not the best
possible takedowns on earth however they
are the best takedowns for situations
with multiple attackers and weapons
being involved
those situations require different kinds
of takedowns and that's what these are
so for takedowns overall are they lower
percentage yes they're definitely lower
percentage four takedowns involving
weapons attackers they are the highest
percentage takedowns you're going to
have right or at least that i've
experienced so far there might be some
stuff out there i haven't seen
absolutely but in in my 20 years of
aikido and sparring and brazilian jiu
jitsu and other martial arts these are
the highest percentage i know that also
because these same takedowns and pins
are used in other martial arts involving
multiple attackers and weapons right so
it's not like aikido has the corner
market on this stuff this steps
available in other places as well so
that's what those things are all about
so the takedowns are one of the big
criticisms you'll see they're not very
good well they're not very good for a
one-on-one unarmed situation
particularly if there's a referee there
to judge if the takedown was good or not
they are the best takedowns you're going
to get for crummy situations where their
arm you're armed or you're both armed
and there's multiple attackers right so
that's the deal with that okay then the
next thing to understand is if you are a
physically super capable person you
could take someone down in any way you
want right so you know my is probably
still a bit of a challenge but you know
if maya was you know maybe about 30
pounds smaller and about five years less
trained then i could probably do
anything i want to her to get her down
right so i can do anything i want to her
to get her down so you why do you need a
super hyped up high percentage take down
technique for someone that you could
take down with any one thing you know if
she was that small you could probably
grab her by the lapels and just push her
down to the ground she's not going to
let me show you that right now but as i
said that would be a smaller less
skilled maya but if i just just grab her
by the lapels and i could smash her down
on the ground then i could do any
takedown i want so i don't need double
leg takedowns or really good hip tosses
or anything like that right
what i need is the most advantageous
takedowns for me so if maya is a 10 year
old and she's got a knife and she's
threatening other 10 year olds what kind
of takedowns do i need the kind of
takedowns that you'll find in aikido so
if i am the physically dominant person
these are the best because every
takedown is going to be high percentage
as far as getting the takedown goes but
these ones will keep me in the safest
best position while i make my takedowns
so that's why these exist so if
someone's critical of these ideas of
takedowns they're right partial but
they're wrong partially and there's
another part that they need to
understand in order to get the full
thing what are the aikido takedowns
for the most part aside from the throws
right so shionage is a way you can take
someone down kokinagi is a way you can
take down someone iridimi nage so all
the nagewaza anything that says otoshi
on it sumiotoshi mayotoshi kazutoshi
means to draw those things can all be
used to take someone down so all of the
nagewaza and the hinko nagewaza which
are a lot of the otoshi's
can be used to take someone down
now other than that udeoce is aikido's
prime takedown method and it's probably
the best when we're talking about our
context as far as just getting the
takedown now an udeoce
looks like an ekyo
most of the time although a ton of
things can be happening so udeo say just
means arm takedown right so this is my
udeo say position right here that's
being done with an echo if i roll her
elbow to a locked position that now
would be done with a rokyo if i
emphasize the gokyo in there that
becomes a gokyo right if i emphasize the
shoulder that's a kata otoshi right so
that shoulder gets smashed down into the
ground that's kata otoshi you can do
variations of kaitenage where you wrap
up and drop down like this but this is
all udeo se arm position this can also
be done gyaku right so our sankyo
takedown is just a gyaku udeyose so i'm
on the opposite side of her body but
it's still udeose
the uriose is super useful because it
isolates that hand and it isolates it
for one of two reasons they're both
useful for our context one is she had a
knife in that actually let me have you
switch to that hand she had a knife in
that hand so there's my udeo say here's
my udese here's variations on my udeose
right so all those things are important
because she had a weapon or if i had a
weapon and she's grabbing me now she
won't let go right so i'm trying to take
her down while she's holding me so i'm
trying all those same methods while
she's holding me so
if i'm armed or if she's armed these
kind of takedowns the uterus they take
down are going to be super super useful
and you're going to use them a lot right
so they're highly functional for our
system udeoce comes in many flavors
right so you can do a gokyo you can do a
rokyo you can do an ikkyo you can do a
sankyo you can do enikyo there's lots of
little things we can add into that udese
you can do it from the regular side or
you can do gyaku right so you can do
either one of those
okay now
once we're on the ground we have one
thing one decision to make which is is
she face up or face down let me show you
what i mean by that
so this is my uh face down or the other
is maya face up so we've gotten a take
down and maya maya's either face up or
face down now in aikido we won't even
mess with her if she's face up we don't
want to try to pin or do anything else
there's one exception
well it depends on the style of aikido
you study in my approach there's one
exception we have which is juji nage and
there's a special reason for that juju
nage exception but other than that we
don't want to mess with it so what we
want to do is get dogai she so her body
to turn over we want to get her body to
turn over now that's done from two basic
ideas either i can have gyakute and
that's because if we were standing i
would be holding her gyakute right you
can see my right hand is grabbing her
left hand that's yakute if we're doing
that we're going to step over this head
so we want to clear the head here and
then as we do that we're going to pull
her around and we're going to set her up
my flipped her body over and we got her
face down
or
i'm going to be katate dory when i do it
you can see now my left hand is grabbing
her left hand when we're katatte we're
going to do a very very similar
procedure except as we come around we're
going to be gyaku when we're done right
we're going to be opposite side okay now
the reason we do that is because we're
assuming she's armed right so let's say
that's in her belt because otherwise
that's not going to work in a second
okay now maybe there's a weapon in this
hand or maybe she's holding my armed
hand right and as i'm dealing with this
hand so i'm going to try to pin her what
she does is she goes for that knife with
the other hand now i got to deal with
this knife right so that's a real
problem for me because there's a weapon
so by assuming there's a weapon what all
the dogai she does is as she goes to get
that weapon
that's fine she can have that weapon and
she comes to try to get me that's fine
it's really weird way to do it i'll take
away that and there's the easy way to do
it and we get all these classic pins
that you would see in something like
taito to you right
so once she's on the ground we have one
decision to make or one thing to
understand is she face up or face down
if she's face up we want to get dogaishi
now there are a few ways to get it the
main ways are katate and gyakute i can
involve using her arm or her wrist to
bring her around right so i can use that
lots of different styles have little
clever ways that they can bring her down
right so i can put pressure against her
elbow to bring her over i can do all
kinds of things sorry this mean i can do
pressure against her shoulder i can
pressure against her wrist to get her to
want to turn over but the reason we
wanted to turn over is because in that
she can't do as much damage to me and i
can see what's coming so i don't want to
even try to pin her unless she's down so
now in jiu-jitsu when she gets like this
i would just jump on top of her right or
already be on top of her because we're
going to grapple around like that
however in an armed situation and
there's a weapon i don't know about
maybe she steals my weapon that's no
good so before i even try to deal with
her pinning i'm going to get gogaishi
i'm going to turn her over the exception
that i said in my school in different
schools have different exceptions is
juji nage which the juji nagy pin looks
like this and you can guess why this is
an okay position because it doesn't
matter if she had a knife in this hand
go ahead and stab me good
yep good job okay if she had a knife in
this hand go ahead and stab me good
yep okay so with the juji nagi we're
counting for both arms and it's done in
the take down so we can we can accept
that okay now once she's on the ground
go ahead and give me a dogaishi like
magic look at this ikea
i did it okay all right
now once we have her here on the ground
like this we're really either going to
be in this position or the opposite
position of this right so one of these
two positions is what we're going to
have
from here our first goal is to get that
shoulder locked down onto the ground now
once her shoulder's locked down on the
ground if she tries to get up
it's really really difficult from here
because her shoulder now let's say she
could get up right so let's say she
could pull up there i have all the time
in the world to escape that position
which again in our multiple attacker
context is what we're looking for right
so in this situation
in this situation she was able to resist
me i'm easily able to escape also from
these positions if i don't already have
a weapon i can get to a weapon now and i
could use a weapon so if she's really
dangerous and i know i'm not going to
hold her i can get to a weapon this is a
lot of what i believe you're seeing in
in uh oh sensei when he's like this
right so you see lots of pins where
osensei is doing this kind of number
right he's really got the handover and
that's because if i had a weapon and you
struggle i'm going to stab you my pin
doesn't have to be that secure because
my weapon is helping to secure you
from this
we have lots of ideas i've talked about
these a little bit in the other series
but i can emphasize locking that elbow
down to the mat right now i can help
emphasize the the wrist right here i can
emphasize the shoulder so i can use all
of those things in order to help me
control her once she's on the ground
okay so
the takedowns are takedowns that involve
multiple attackers and weapons that's
why we take down the way we do
those are not the highest percentage
takedowns overall but they're the
highest percentage for the context we're
talking about once they're on the ground
we try to get them to be belly down if
we can't get them belly down we abate
right we get out of there we use our
weapon that we have to use right they're
already in a vulnerable position but
we're assuming either a i'm so strong
and capable of holding them down or b
i am they're they're giving in to me and
letting me do what i want because
they're scared of what i might possibly
to them either of those situations if
they start to come back at me i just
abate that situation right so i just get
out of there boom and i use my weapon
once she's face down i go in to control
and isolate the arm so by holding the
arm out that's probably the weapon arm
i'm now isolating it from the rest of
the body the only other choice you'll
have is to to reach underneath and get
another weapon i will see that weapon
come out way in advance and be able to
deal with that as it arises right so
that's the ose komiwaza that's an
overview of how it works and why it
works the way it does in my opinion it's
a very important part of aikido although
it can be confusing thing to understand
remember in aikido at least as my
approach says it the goal is always to
get back to making a cord so the pin is
used as a way to make a cord
i now don't have to cut this
five-year-old down or shoot them or
whatever else i can hold them until help
arrives and we can all take care of that
that that kid in a very easy and gentle
way you might need to use things like
that if you're in a physically dominant
position if you're dealing with someone
who's got mental
capacity problems or someone who's
younger or someone who's older or all
kinds of things people get freaked out
and you might need to control that
person but not do it in a way that
involves elbowing in the nose and
breaking their face the other side of
that is i got lucky in a situation with
a really dangerous person and i was able
to get them down
i'm going to hold them tentatively
because that's the best option i have
right now but if they give me too much
resistance i'm gonna get out of there
and go back to my weapon platform
because that's what i have to do so
that's the way aikido pinning techniques
are built i'm christopher hine this is
maya solano mcdaniel and again the ghost
is behind the camera josh got a cold i
think it's just a cold but he's scared
that it might be covered so he's doing
the right thing he stayed home he's
getting a test
so hopefully we'll have him back here
with us really really soon thanks for
watching
[Music]
you